bonjour à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous on dirait que sur rt france
basma maghrebi cette mobilisation qui ne
faiblit pas c'est le neuvième samedi
consécutif quelle lecture en faites vous
la lecture j'en fais c'est que les
citoyens sont vraiment fidèle à ils
tiennent énormément au respect de leur
liberté
la mise en place de ce pass sanitaire
porte une atteinte grave et manifeste
libertés fondamentales des citoyens ils
en ont conscience et ils entendent le
faire savoir et faire valoir leurs
droits par rapport à ça qu'elle aime
qu'elle fleurit pensez vous que les
français finalement ne sont pas assez
convaincu par l'efficacité des vaccins
anti qu'ovide
effectivement il ya un problème de
défiance par rapport à cette campagne de
vaccination et le problème c'est qu'on
ne pouvoir tu es tellement discrédité
par tous les mensonges et les
contre-vérités les ordres et les
comprend de plus ils poussent les gens
plus ils les presses à aller vers cette
vaccination et puis il ya une résistance
qui se fait sentir c'est malheureux
parce que du coup il ya une confusion
entre une opposition politique un geste
salutaire il est tout à fait justifié
basma maghrébine vous êtes avocat tant
sur le plan juridique on a l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants qui va entrer en
vigueur le 15 septembre qu'en
pensez-vous de cette obligation
alors à mon sens cette obligation
vaccinale est totalement prématurée une
égard au statut du vaccin alors il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui tentent pas
nous dire que le fait que ce vaccin est
une obligation qui est une autorisation
de mise sur le marché par don
permet de justifier cette obligation
alors que au niveau européen on a quand
même des règles des règles qui ont été
co été annoncé qu'ils sont assez simple
on ne rend pas un vaccin obligatoire
lorsqu'on n'a pas suffisamment de recul
d'1 sur la maladie et de 2 sur le vaccin
lui-même or en l'occurrence dans la
mesure où on a une autorisation de mise
sur le marché conditionnelle je ne vois
pas et je ne comprends pas comment on
peut rendre ce vaccin obligatoire
quatre fois oui cette histoire d'
immunité collective dont on entendait
parler au début de la crise sanitaire
finalement pourquoi ce n'est plus d'un
crédités
mais ce qui se passe c'est que déjà il
faut dire que la théorie des collectifs
c'est une théorie on théorise et qu'avec
la contagiosité du premier virus on a eu
il y avait besoin d'avoir 65 % de la
population est immunisée pour que
finalement ce virus commencèrent arrêté
de circuler or là il a lutté plusieurs
fois on a eu plusieurs variants il va y
en avoir encore d'autres et le variant
delta notamment est beaucoup plus
contagieux à peu près de deux fois plus
que le précédent le premier est donc
cette immunité collective maintenant on
estime que ces
95% de la population qui devrait être
immunisé pour arriver à cette immunité
collective ce qui devient un objectif
assez peu atteignable et surtout à
l'image à l'échelle de la planète parce
que c'est bien le problème cette
stratégie dix minutes et collective n'a
de sens qu'à l'échelle de la planète si
vous avez des pays qui continue qui ne
sont pas immunisés parce que par exemple
qu'il n'y a pas de campagne de
vaccination pour super à aux
contaminations et bien vous allez avoir
un virus qui continuent à circuler qui
continuent à lutter et il risque avant
d'avoir des limitations qui lui donne un
avantage sélectif parce que ces
mutations il permet de passer dans la
population active c'est ce qu'on voit
avec le variant de la varenne delta un
petit peu et on commençait à voir avec
le bar y en aura peut-être d'autres ap
bassin maghrébine êtes avocate remet
également membre du collectif 1 santé et
liberté quelles sont les missions
l'objectif d'autres collectifs alors
l'objectif de notre collectif et de
dénoncer justement les atteintes aux
libertés fondamentales qui sont hélas
manifeste par l'élargissement du pass
sanitaire parce qu'en réalité ce qu'on
conteste ce n'est pas le pass and i
termine en lui-même mais l'élargissement
de ce pass à lutter aux actes de la vie
quotidienne on considère qu' on ne peut
pas porter atteinte de cette manière là
à nos libertés dallaire notre liberté
d'aller et venir au droit au secret
médical au droit à l'intégrité physique
au droit lundi à la viola bilité du
corps humain le gouvernement a la
possibilité de mener une campagne
vaccinale en essayant de faire en sorte
d'obtenir la confiance des citoyens
d'obtenir l'adhésion des citoyen sans
avoir à porter atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales de tous et c'est vraiment
le message qu'on essaye de porter et
d'ailleurs dans la tribune on a qu'on a
signé on est plus de 300 avocats où on
affirme bien qu'on ait ni contre le
vaccin ni pro vaccin on est pour le
respect des libertés parce que à mon
sens c'est à notre sens il ya d'autres
moyens de pouvoir réussir à lutter
contre cette crise sanitaire sans avoir
à porter atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux de tous
karim quel foyer je vous voyais à quai
c'est un pan dans les propos de bassma
maghrebi vous aussi vous pensez
finalement que le gouvernement français
aurait dû le pousser la vaccination et
sans passer par le passé ni terre
mais clairement c'est à dire que toute
forme de contrainte et peut être
contre-productif c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est l' oms le msl dit bien que la
meilleure manière d'arriver à une
campagne de vaccination qui est un
succès c'est le convaincre et pas de
contraindre aujourd'hui le gouvernement
fait précisément inverse et j'ai envie
de dire il fait précisément l'inversé
aussi pour des raisons qui ne sont pas
que sanitaire mais qui sont politicienne
parce que il y avait des vagues
notamment cette delta qui arrive et on
aura sans doute d'autres après et qu' il
ne voulait plus assumer la
responsabilité de confinement et de
couvre feu qui était impopulaire et donc
ils ont préférer scinder la population 2
avec ceux qui avaient le droit de se
déplacer d'avoir des activités
quotidiennes
de loisirs etc et ceux qui ne pouvaient
plus y prétendre parce qu'il refusait la
vaccination c'était aussi une manière de
montrer comme bouc émissaire et les
responsables et les grands irresponsable
plutôt seraient les gens qui refusent de
se faire vacciner alors que les seuls
responsables dans une crise est en
général ce sont le gouvernement et les
ministres on voit que lorsqu'une
ministre notamment l'ancien misa santé
et mise en examen tout le monde commence
à pousser des cris d'orfraie en disant
que c'est pas normal ça va mener à
paralyser des politiques etc c'est une
vaste blague si les ministres ne qui
sont les responsables ne sont pas jugés
pour leur responsabilité surtout quand
il ya des manquements aussi grave et des
mensonges aussi grave il y en a eu alors
qui est responsable
à part la cour la population comme
semble vouloir l'indiqué à chaque fois
le gouvernement basma malgré me on va
revenir justement cette mise en examen
de l'ancien ministre de la santé ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne nouvelle que
la justice commence en tout cas à
examiner un peu ce qui s'est passé
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
et la façon dont le gouvernement
français l'algérie bien évidemment c est
une excellente c'est une excellente
nouvelle parce que je pense que la seule
larme que nous ayons c'est larmes du
droit et le respect du droit et larmes
de la justice elle vaque à son travail
et elle se prononcera par rapport à ça
mais bien évidemment que c'est une c'est
une excellente c'est une excellente
nouvelle je je tenais aussi à à rebondir
sur sur ce qui avait été dit
précédemment par par le docteur je
voulais juste apporter une précision
c'est que là où ou le pass sanitaire est
également extrêmement grave c'est qu'on
on essaye de nous faire croire au niveau
du gouvernement qu on n'est pas face à
une obligation vaccinale on n'est pas
face à une obligation de contraindre les
gens à se faire vacciner or contraindre
les gens à présenter un pass à lutter
pour pouvoir se poser dans une terrasse
à café et contraindre les gens à
présenter un pas de sanitaires pour les
actes de tous les jours contre en
sachant que le pack sanitaire c'est soit
un vaccin soit un test pcr soit le fait
de l'avoir déjà eu et bien c'est c'est
contraindre indirectement les gens à se
faire vacciner donc c'est une obligation
vaccinale déguisés et c'est extrêmement
grave parce que là ça porte atteinte aux
droits au libre consentement des
personnes parce que aujourd'hui on a
énormément de citoyens qui se font
vacciner non pas pour les bonnes raisons
mais qui se font vacciner uniquement
pour pouvoir exercer leur liberté
fondamentale et c'est d'autant plus
grave qu'elle aime quatre fois rien vous
êtes docteur un bien évidemment vous
n'êtes pas visionnaire mais il ya quand
même question qui revient souvent est ce
qu'on va devoir vivre apprendre en tout
cas vivre avec le co vide
écoutez je ne peux pas faire de
pronostics mais c'est ma craint parce
que en réalité la vaccination c'est une
arme efficace c'est clair il faut le
dire pour les formes graves salé limite
énormément pour la contamination ça les
limites aussi mais c'est pas parfait
donc on aura encore des contaminations
et puis comme je le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez la moitié de la
planète qui n'a pas accès à la
vaccination ben avait pas de chance
d'arriver à une véritable unité
collective et le virus risque de
continuer à circuler pour combien de
temps le sait pas est ce qu'à un moment
le virus va aussi limiter de manière à
ce qu'ils soient un peu moins virulent
et qu'on se met à vivre avec un peu
comme on peut vivre avec des tonnes de
virus hin1 courante c'est possible aussi
tous les scénarios sont envisageables
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à mon avis
la la la campagne basée sur les émotions
où on voit par exemple une vieille dame
qui rêve de prendre sa petite fille dans
les bras
alors qu'elle se fait vacciner parce
qu'elle se fait vacciner et qu elle le
fait sans gestes barrières on lui laisse
entendre en gros elle va pouvoir
retourner à une vie normale sans sans
aucune précaution et qu'en plus de ça il
ya le l'injonction contradictoires à la
fin de du message qui vous dit respecter
les gestes barrière c'est ça s'appelle
de la désinformation c'est de l'afld et
news donc à un moment il faut qu'ils
arrêtent les campagnes de ce type il
faut qu'ils nous remettent ce pareil le
chantage avec la musique freedom c'est
insupportable expliquer aux gens
l'intérêt du vaccin expliqué quels en
sont les avantages et les limites et
poucet de cette manière là se faire
vacciner sans passer en permanence par
la vaccination est à côté il ya plus
qu'un tas de mesures annexes qu'il faut
prendre par exemple des mesures
techniques comme l'installation des
purificateurs d'air il en faut par tous
les capteurs de co2 il en faut partout
parce qu'on sait que c'est en intérieur
on va se faire comprendre qu'on se
contaminent il faut des politiques de
distribution de masques ffp2 à l'entrée
des métros à l'entrée des bus à l'entrée
des lieux publics voilà ça c'est des
politiques volontaristes qui nous
aideront aussi à limiter les
contaminations sans avoir à fracturer la
société française et a limité les ânes
les libertés individuelles de chacun
karim quatre feuilles vous êtes médecin
généraliste merci à vous d'avoir répondu
à nos questions et ce malgré vous est
avocate et membre du collectif santé et
libertés merci à vous également merci à
vous deux d'abord et en direct sur rt
france aujourd'hui